Being a tried wife online is a really crazy thing
because you run across a lot of people
who don't understand having a set of values
that you make your life decisions from.
The people with the most opinions on what it means to be a tried wife
are not the people in the tried community,
but actually people who are completely opposite
and against what tried wives believe and stand for.
They have this limited, oppressed view of what it means to be trapped
and they try to put us in this box
when we break their made up stereotypes.
They say, oh,
you aren't a tried wife as if they get to define who we are.
I have never had another tried wife say that
I'm not tried because I have a side hustle.
But I have had many outside the community tell me that
being traditional is not a 1950s cosplay cult
or a Little House on the Prairie cosplay cult.
Being traditional is having a set of values
that you make your life decisions from.
We all do this. It's called having a world view.
Because I am a Christian, my set of values comes from the Bible.
I make my decisions based off what it says about me
and how to live my life. And because it's not a cult,
another person can base their life decisions off the Bible
and have a completely different life.
For me, that's the beauty of it.
No one Gets to define who I am,
except for god. Not a community,
not strangers on the internet,
not an aesthetic that I'm obsessed with.
Who I am comes from an understanding of the Bible.
Because if it starts coming from man made rules, it will become a cult.